in constituencies around the country you
find politicians embattled an endangered
species and that goes double for Liberal
Democrats also you'd think the most
beleaguered party nationally is also the
most expert when it comes to grassroots
politics Sutton and team Lib Dem MP Lib
Dem dominated council and it seems
people can't get enough as the Liberal
Democrat vote nationally has collapsed
incredibly polls suggest the local MP
Paul burst Oh is increasing his share of
the vote how on earth can he do that
it's very high-profile in this area I've
seen I work at a local hospital what
have they done for you I think you
certainly see them about I mean we see
our MP about and in terms of what he
says about school care for older people
hospitals those those sorts of things
that that people really want to know
about around here so it seems like he's
talking about things that we were
interested in Paul burst oh who is my MP
has been excellent I've emailed him on
lots of topics especially health-related
as I've had 44 years of Nursing and I
found it very supportive and I would
vote for him again he's been very vocal
on things like savings and heylia's the
hospital which is very important to
people who live around here especially
people got children and born there it's
sort of identifying with somebody who
you actually know I think that's very
important when it comes to any in being
local services generally speaking things
we put at the top of the agenda so I
think that's a reasonable you know sort
of perspective on why most people would
vote for them the Conservatives have
pretty much set up shop in Sutton and
team they've plunged huge amounts of
effort and resource into a seat that
they feel should have their name on it
in this tightest of elections the
Conservatives need the Lib Dems to
collapse in seats like Sutton and cheap
but they're not going quietly
the Tories find their coalition partners
a bit of a pain these days imagine how
much more irritated they'll be if Lib
Dems end up obstructing their route to a
parliamentary majority
you